[Music]
so living systems have you know one of
my teachers is sally corner she was our
science science advisor until she
retired and we still draw on her work
extensively she she taught us that
living systems have weather what are
called healthy hierarchies so it's not
that hierarchy is bad it's that
hierarchy that where the top extracts
from below is is definitely bad and
unsustainable so you know take the lion
in in the forest or in the jungle the
lion is at the top of the food chain but
the lion sits around sleeping most a day
rather than eating and killing all day
and in the line therefore serves a very
healthy purpose hierarchical purpose in
the food chain keeping you know keeping
the herd keeping the balance between
smaller animals and large animals but
but when the then when the king of the
jungle decides to extract as much as
possible for its own benefit you have a
you have a very unhealthy system and
unfortunately that's pretty well
describes what what the modern
capitalist system works where the
there's there's benefits of scale the
bigger get bigger they get more powerful
they get more political influence but
their intention is to maximize
shareholder value because that's what we
do so the the cycle of of growing
inequality is sort of locked in to the
system design now how we deal with that
in in a human economy is it's not
trivial you know the the oak tree knows
in a forest that it serves to support a
lot of life I suspect the only answer in
the short term we have in a human
economy is an enlightened regulatory
regime that understands these principles
and has incentives and disincentives
that cause the market players to move
toward a more healthy hierarchy so for
example in the banking sector and this
actually exists post the financial
crisis it's just not extreme enough
there are disincentives to becoming big
and complex they're just not strong
enough they should be in my opinion be
strong enough that it would force the JP
Morgan's and the Goldman Sachs's of the
world to on their own
volition becomes smaller and less
complex and become more in alignment
with in in in service of the economy so
the things they do that are extractive
should get penalized and the things that
they do are in service of the real
economy which they do do should should
should get incentivized so you don't
need to quote break up the banks you
need to create incentive system that
causes them to behave in such a way that
they be aligned with the principles of
living systems which by the way are
fractal every living system again going
back to your body your cardiovascular
system is fractal you have a few large
veins a lot of medium-sized capillaries
and tons and tons are medium-sized veins
and tons and tons of capillaries that
fractal system exists in oak trees and
in humans and in river systems and in
lightning bolts so it's a it's a strong
argument in favor of not allowing the
banking system or any sector of the
economy to be so concentrated with a few
massive firms that then end up
undermining the health of the small ones
which is essentially what's happened
across our entire economy so you know my
work around this idea of regenerative
economics started through this journey
of discovery trying to wrestle with
what's actually at the root cause of our
modern economic system and that's a bit
of a long story but I can't really jump
to the conclusion without giving a
little bit of context so I think we're
we're in a much bigger shift than most
of us yet realize we're in a shift for
in in an understanding of how our
economies actually have to work and
we've been in what is called the modern
age since the Scientific Revolution and
the secret to the modern age or the
magic of the modern age was the
scientific method and reducing what's
complicated in two buckets that can be
understood and that reductionist method
is been the driver of great progress in
many many areas you know an iPhone or a
bicycle or a car are all products of a
reductionist mindset and since we've
been in
that mode for 400 years it's literally
baked into our DNA at this point the
only problem with a reductionist method
is that it's not the way the universe
actually works you as an individual are
not the sum of the parts of your body
and you know that you're only healthy if
those parts are all working
symbiotically together as a whole the
reductionist method what people refer to
as the mechanistic age doesn't allow us
to keep track of the whole and many of
the problems that are manifesting in our
economy I believe have a root cause in
the limitation of the reductionist
method so for example we discover oil we
burn oil we have all this great growth
in all this great progress but we didn't
know burning oil would create releasing
gases to the point that we would heat
the climate so it's an unintended
consequence that only a holistic
understanding of how gases in the
atmosphere affect the weather systems
that is linked to our energy use could
one have seen that problem so now we're
trapped in a system that is burning
fossil fuels at greater and greater
rates and yet we have already the
consequences of climate change with
predictions that are literally dire for
for Humanity and other living species on
the planet so to get to regenerative
economy you first have to say well that
system is fundamentally unsustainable it
cannot go on forever and and we will
either burn up the planet or on the
social side we will increase inequality
to the point that we have civil strife
and civil wars and so my search was
really for you know how could one design
an economic system that didn't have
those outcomes and I know I'm not smart
enough to figure that out so the the
idea is really very simple
living systems that sustain themselves
in the natural world work in accordance
with certain patterns and principles
your body does an entire rainforest does
and so the work we're doing at capital
Institute which is building on the
shoulders of many many people that have
been thinking this way
for for literally for centuries this
holistic approach to understanding
systems is really the the root or the
source of what this idea is we call
regenerative economies so think of a
regenerative economy as as the design
principles that work in sustainable
living systems they're the it's the
process that allows a system to be
sustainable as opposed to sustainability
which is kind of a goal which is boy if
we can just reduce these problems we can
get to sustainability we believe you
only have a sustainable system whether
it's a human person or an entire
ecosystem or a business or an entire
economy if it follows the same patterns
and principles that living systems work
in accordance with and what's magical
about it is that it turns out those
principles and patterns are very aligned
with the wisdom traditions Eastern
Western Eastern in particular but
Eastern Western and indigenous that have
been around for for for many many
thousands of years so at the end of the
day my my argument is you know either
make the case that the human economy is
the only example of a system that
doesn't need to obey the same patterns
and principles that all other living
systems that sustain themselves follow
or we better figure out how to get the
human economy in alignment with those
principles and and and and regenerative
economics is the beginning of inquiry
into what that looks like and how one
might actually manifest that in the
world
[Music]